الاردن والملايين حول العالم شهدوا حفل
زفاف تاريخيا الامير الحسين والاميره رجوى
فيما كانت هذه اللقطات ضمن اخر مراسم
الزفاف لكن كيف بدات مراسم هذا الفرح
الكبير بدات بوصول الملك عبد الله الثاني
والملكه رانيا الى قصر زهران في العاصمه
عمان لاستقبال وتحيه ضيوف الحفل وبعد ذلك
وصل العريس الامير الحسين لينضم الى والده
ووالدته للترحيب بالضيوف ثم وصلت الانسه
رجوى خالد السيف يرافقها الامير هاشم بن
عبد الله الثاني لتبدا هنا مراسم عقد
القران التي حضرها حوالي 140 ضيفا بمن
فيهم افراد من العائله الهاشميه وافراد
عائلات مالكه من دول العالم وبعد توقيع
العروسين والشاهدين على العقد اختتم
الامام المراسم بادعيه متمنيا لهما زواجا
مباركا وتزامن ذلك مع منح العهد الارد
الانسه رجوى ال سيف لقب صاحبه السمو
الملكي الاميره رجوى لمناسبه عقد قرانها
على ولي العهد وبعد ذلك انطلق العروسان
بموكب الزفاف في مسار الاحتفال من قصر
الزهران الى قصر الحسينيه غربي عمان حيث
تمكن الالاف من المشاركه في الاحتفال
بالموكب من خلال سبعه مواقع موزعه على
طريق الموكب الملكي الاحمر ولد وصول
الموكب الى قصر الحسينيه بدا حفل الزفاف
باستقبال العروسين بحضور حوالي
1700 مدعو
[موسيقى]